several hundred people were in
attendance last night in Iowa as ten
Democratic candidates for president
discussed LGBTQ issues as the race for
the White House picks up candidates are
looking for ways to connect with voters
and that includes leaving supporters
with a lasting memory of their encounter
with a potential future President of the
United States CBS News political
reporter Katelyn Huey Burns is here with
more
Caitlin good morning good morning
Michelle well the most popular element
of the campaign trail these days isn't
necessarily a policy proposal or a stump
speech it's the selfie line it's a new
way for voters to connect with
candidates putting a new spin on retail
politics now some of the photos you're
about to see don't always technically
fit the definition of a selfie but
here's a snapshot from the modern
campaign they came they saw thank you
thank you
they selfie in the race for the White
House so called selfie lines have become
a key feature of campaign events with
voters willing to wait hours to take a
photo with a candidate we waited in line
and it was worth it campaigns have
professionalized the picture-taking
experience and made it central to their
digital strategy the real measure of
democracy more than 50 thousand selfies
photo lines are such a priority for
Elizabeth Warren's campaign that she
even changes into sneakers to prepare
a grassroots movement small-dollar Gemma
Nations volunteers and selfie live
warrants selfie line is a fine-tuned
operation there's a person in every task
you know somebody to take the phone from
you hand it off to the person that
actually takes the picture of you while
you're with Liz they say a picture is
worth a thousand words but for these
campaigns they are actually worth a
thousand impressions photo lines
act as a mass marketing tool a photo
taken is a photo shared serving as free
digital advertising for candidates we
live in a kind of social media there is
a multiplier effect anybody who gets a
selfie with you will often post it
online their friends will see that as
well and it helps to generate you know
some virtuous morality digital analysts
say the shared photos amount to major
savings for the campaigns all while
generating grassroots momentum to make
sure they can take a picture
it is one of the most important and
meaningful interactions that I have at
any of these events usually on my team
members with me now so okay we have to
follow up with this person some
candidates have developed their own
selfie protocol first thing you got to
know is how to hack into any phone and
so most people don't know that they put
their code and they take a long time
actually by taking it myself I can just
swipe with one finger and be at your
camera Joe Biden is known to take his
own selfies and often makes emotional
connections with people on the photo
line people what do you say to a woman
who says I lost my child and if we had
decent health care that would not have
been the case that is just it moves you
to the core the selfie lines also
influenced policy proposals is there a
plan that was specifically directly
influenced by your conversations on yes
in fact I distinctly remember meeting
the woman in the selfie line chris said
why don't you commit that your Secretary
of Education will be someone who taught
in public school you're on and sometimes
they even bring competitors together as
friends now Elizabeth Warren held a
four-hour long selfie line earlier this
week and the campaign tells me they are
now up to 60,000 selfies showing no
signs of slowing down anytime soon in
fact our own ed O'Keefe spotted the
senator at the airport this week are
booked on their way - and look what we
have here a selfie line impromptu
forming at the airport so this is
something that we're going to continue
to see for a long time it's a way to
butter up and warm up you know
it's a moment that you have maybe it
used to be a handshake in that handshake
line and it just has grown into that
that moment where maybe you connect you
still find out how your candidate has a
stand on which issues but still it's
your moment to connect and we've talked
to so many voters coming off these
selfie lines over the past few months
and the chance to really meet someone in
person in this intimate reaction they
really take a lot away from and they're
also able to talk to these candidates
Elizabeth Warren says that she gets
notes passed to her all the time and she
reads them other candidates say that
they you know really take away a lot
from your conversations
kaylynn it is so good to have you here
you've been travelling like crazy and Ed
and the whole rest of our team so we
appreciate it thank you so much long
road ahead not even to no fabric we
really start